porque, bueno, no cuestan nada.
Creo que estas soluciones son un símbolo de esta época
de algo que tan a menudo tratamos como síntomas
mientras ignoramos la causa subyacente.
Así que me pregunto:
¿por qué no cambiamos el entorno en el que viven los pobres?
O, si volvemos al ejemplo anterior de la computadora,
¿por qué no dejamos de retocar el software
cuando podríamos resolver fácilmente el problema instalando más memoria?
Llegados a este punto, el profesor Shafir respondió con una mirada vacía.
Y al cabo de unos segundos, dijo:
"Entiendo.
Quieres decir que hay que darles más dinero a los pobres
para erradicar la pobreza.
Bueno, claro, sería estupendo.
Pero me temo que el tipo de política de izquierdas
que se practica en Ámsterdam...
no existe en EE.UU."
¿Pero es de verdad esta idea algo anticuado y de izquierdas?
Recuerdo haber leído algo acerca de un plan antiguo,
algo que propusieron unos de los mejores pensadores de la historia.
El filósofo Thomas More aludió a esto en su libro "Utopía",
hace más de 500 años.
Y sus defensores han sido tanto de derechas como de izquierdas
desde el activista para los derechos civiles, Martin Luther King,
hasta el economista Milton Friedman.
Y se trata de una idea increíblemente simple:
la garantía de un ingreso básico universal.
¿Qué es esto?
Bueno, es algo fácil.
Es un ingreso mensual que basta para cubrir necesidades básicas:
comida, cobijo, educación.
Es algo totalmente exento de obligaciones
de modo que nadie puede decirles qué tienen que hacer para obtenerlo
y nadie puede decirles qué tienen que hacer con eso.
El ingresó básico no es un favor, es un derecho.
Y no es un estigma.
Mientras aprendía sobre la verdadera naturaleza de la pobreza,
no pude dejar de preguntarme:
¿Es esta la idea que tanto esperábamos?
¿Realmente puede ser tan fácil?
Y en los siguientes tres años,
me dediqué a leer todo lo que pude encontrar sobre el ingreso básico,
las decenas de experimentos que se llevaron a cabo en todo el mundo,
y muy pronto di con la historia de un pueblo que la puso en práctica,
que realmente erradicó la pobreza.
Pero muy pronto cayó en el olvido.
Esta historia empieza en Dauphin, Canadá.
En 1974, a todos los que vivían en este pueblo se les otorgó un ingreso básico
de modo que nadie viviera por debajo del umbral de la pobreza.
Al principio del experimento,
un ejército de investigadores invadieron el pueblo.
Todo marchó bien durante cuatro años.
Pero luego, un nuevo gobierno ganó las elecciones
y el nuevo gabinete canadiense pensó que este experimento resultaba caro
de modo que al quedarse sin dinero para analizar los resultados del experimento
los investigadores recogieron todos sus datos en 2000 cajas y se marcharon.
Veinticinco años más tarde,
Evelyn Forget, una profesora canadiense volvió a topar con los expedientes,
y durante tres años los analizó de todos los puntos de vista estadísticos
y da igual lo que aplicaba a los registros,
sus resultados eran los mismos:
este experimento fue un éxito tremendo.
Evelyn Forget descubrió
que los habitantes de Dauphin no solo se volvieron más ricos
sino que también más listos y más sanos.
El rendimiento escolar de los niños mejoró sustancialmente.
La tasa de hospitalización disminuyó en un 8,5 %.
Los incidentes de violencia doméstica disminuyeron
igual que los problemas de salud mental.
Y la gente seguía empleada.
Los únicos que trabajaron un poco menos eran las madres y los estudiantes,
ya que estos prolongaban el tiempo dedicado a sus estudios.
Se han encontrado resultados similares
en otros incontables experimentos a nivel global,
desde EE.UU. hasta India.
De modo que...
es es lo que yo aprendí:
en materia de pobreza,
nosotros, los ricos, deberíamos dejar de fingir que sabemos mejor
como erradicarla
y deberíamos dejar de enviarles a los pobres zapatos y peluches...
y a los que ni conocemos.
Y debemos deshacernos del vasto ejército de burócratas paternalistas
que harían mejor en regalar sus ingresos a estos pobres
si realmente quieren ayudar.
(Aplausos)
Porque lo importante del dinero
es que la gente puede usarlo para comprar lo que les hace falta
en lugar de las cosas que dictaminen expertos que nadie necesita.
Imagínense cuántos científicos brillantes y emprendedores
y escritores como George Orwell
lo pasaron mal en la escasez.
Imagínense cuánta energía y talento se desencadenaría
si nos deshiciéramos de la pobreza de una vez por todas.
Creo que un ingreso básico funcionaría como capital de riesgo para el pueblo.
Y no nos podemos permitir no hacerlo
porque la pobreza cuesta mucho.
Basta con mirar el costo de la pobreza infantil en EE.UU., por ejemplo.
Se estima en USD 500 000 millones cada año, en lo que viene a ser
un gasto mayor en la atención sanitaria, mayores tasas de deserción escolar
y más crímenes.
Esto es un desperdicio increíble del potencial humano.
Pero hablemos de lo que todos evitan hablar.
¿Cómo podríamos permitir asegurar un ingreso básico?
Bueno, en realidad es mucho más barato de lo que Uds. piensan.
En Dauphin
lo financiaron con un impuesto sobre la renta en negativo.
Esto significa que sus ingresos suben
tan pronto como hayan bajado al umbral de la pobreza.
En este caso, y según las mejores estimaciones de nuestros economistas,
por un costo neto de USD 175 000 millones
-- o un cuarto del gasto militar estadounidense, o 1 % del PIB --
se pueden sacar a los estadounidenses empobrecidos de la pobreza.
Se puede realmente erradicar la pobreza.
Esa debe ser nuestra meta.
(Aplausos)
La época de las soluciones pobres y los pequeños empujones ha pasado.
Realmente creo que ha llegado el momento para las nuevas ideas radicales,
y el ingreso básico es mucho más que solo otra política más.
De hecho, es un replanteamiento completamente novedoso
de lo que realmente es el trabajo.
Y en este sentido, no solo liberará a los pobres sino a todos nosotros.
Hoy en día, millones de personas sienten que sus trabajos tienen poco sentido.
Una encuesta reciente entre 230 000 empleados
de 142 países
encontró que solo al 13 % de los encuestados les gusta su trabajo.
Otra encuesta encontró que hasta el 37 % de los trabajadores británicos
creen que su trabajo ni siquiera debería existir.
Es como dice Brad Pitt en el "Club de la pelea":
"Demasiado a menudo tenemos trabajos que odiamos
para poder comprar tonterías que no necesitamos".
(Risas)
Bueno, no me malinterpreten...
No estoy hablando de los profesores, los basureros o los auxiliares sanitarios
porque entonces tendríamos un problema.
Estoy hablando de todos estos profesionales
bien pagados y con currículos excelentes
que ganan su dinero en reuniones estratégicas
y transacciones personalizadas
durante una tormenta de ideas que añade un valor suplementario
a la co-creación disruptiva de una sociedad en redes.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
O algo por el estilo.
Solo imagínense de nuevo cuánto talento estamos desperdiciando,
simplemente porque les decimos a nuestros hijos que tendrán
que "ganarse la vida".
O lo que un genio de la matemáticas trabajando para Facebook lamentaba
hace unos años: "Las mejores mentes de mi generación
se preocupan por cómo hacer que la gente haga clic en los anuncios".
Soy historiador.
Y si la historia nos ha enseñado algo
es que las cosas pueden cambiar,
que nada es inevitable
en la estructura actual de nuestra sociedad y economía.
Las ideas pueden y realmente cambian el mundo.
Y creo que especialmente en los últimos años
se ha vuelto muy evidente el hecho
de que el statu quo actual no es sostenible
y de que nos hacen falta nuevas ideas.
Sé que muchos de Uds. ven un futuro de creciente desigualdad,
xenofobia y cambio climático.
Pero no es suficiente con resaltar las cosas a las que nos oponemos,
sino que también debemos afirmar aquello con lo que estamos a favor.
Martin Luther King no dijo que tenía una pesadilla.
(Risas)
Él tenía un sueño.
(Aplausos)
Así que...
aquí declaro mi sueño:
creo en un futuro donde el valor de nuestro trabajo no se defina
por la cantidad del ingreso
sino por la cantidad de felicidad que uno infunda
y la cantidad de sentido que uno genere.
Creo en un futuro
donde la meta de un sistema educativo
no sea prepararse para un trabajo inútil sino para una vida bien aprovechada.
Creo en un futuro donde vivir sin pobreza
no sea un privilegio sino un derecho bien merecido de todos.
Hasta aquí hemos llegado.
Aquí estamos:
hemos investigado, tenemos la evidencia y tenemos los medios.
Hace más de 500 años, Thomas More escribió por primera vez
sobre el ingreso básico,
y hace más de 100 años,
George Orwell descubrió la verdadera naturaleza de la pobreza;
lo único que hace falta cambiar es nuestra visión
ya que la pobreza no es una falta de carácter
sino una falta de dinero.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)